وقد اكد الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد المضي في
المسيره التي يقودها حتى يعيش تونسيونا
كما قال حياه كريمه ولتجريب البلاد
الانقسام والفتنه واشار على الرئيس سعيد
الى مواجهه كثير من المصاعب التي منها
الطبيعي ومنها المفتعل وخلال تراسه جلسه
للمجلس الوزراء قال انما انجز في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه لم يكن هائلا على الاطلاق
حيث تم احترام المواعيد كلها بالنسبه لوضع
الدستور وتنظيم الاستفتاء وانتخابات مجلس
الشعب واكد الرئيس التونسي ان المعركه
اليوم هي المعركه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
ضد من عاثوا في البلاد فسادا للاستجابه
لمطالب التونسيين
وقال رئيس تونسي الى خطوات جديده ستتخذ
واولها دعوه مجلس النواب لانعقاد فضلا عن
النظر في مشروع يتعلق بحل المجالس البلديه
كما سيتم النظر كذلك في مشروعي مرسومين
يتعلقان
بتنقيح القانون الانتخابي لاعضاء المجلس
البلديه
ثم
مشروع يتعلق
بانتخاب اعضاء المجلس الوطني للجهادي
والاقاليم
الى جانب نص اخر
يتعلق
بحل المجالس البلديه كلها
وتعويضها
[موسيقى]
خصوصيه
صحيح ان الاوضاع الماليه صعبه
بالرغم من اننا لم نتسبب فيها على الاطلاق
ولكنه اي اختيار
لمواجهه هذه الاوضاع
يجب ان يكون نابعا من اراده شعبنا لا على
حسابه
كما ان المعركه
التي نقودها بالقانون
ضد الذين
عاصوا في البلاد فساده
ستستمر
بنفس القوه
وبنفس العزم